Я можу сказати, що, на мою думку, велика проблема
нашої української історичної школи в тому,
що вона відірвана від сприйняття
простою людиною, не пов'язаною з історією.
Тобто історія існує в одному світі,
суспільство — в іншому.
А популярний медійний проєкт часто-густо
дуже далекий від справжніх історичних реалій.
Ми вже давно цим займаємось,
якщо говорити про реконструкцію.
Це ще дитяче та підліткове захоплення історією.
Поступово бажання це все пізнати тактильно,
«на дотик», а не в теорії, збільшувалося.
Ми займаємося історією нашої малої батьківщини.
Власне Поділлям і Кам'янцем зокрема.
Найдавніший період, яким ми займаємося, —
перша половина XVII століття
в історії міста Кам'янця та замку Кам'янецького.
Зараз я трошки інакше вже дивлюся на замок,
не просто як реконструктор чи відвідувач.
Я вже розумію, що впливає на нього.
Треба розуміти, що потік туристів,
який зараз проходить через замок,
разів у 8-10 більший, ніж 12 років тому.
Цей потік туристів впливає на вигляд замку.
Ми зараз вимушені
дбати насамперед про благоустрій.
Про те, щоб безпечно і зручно
такий потік людей міг тут проходити.
Поступово від гри
за останніх 7-8 років дійшли до того,
що це перетворилося
в усвідомлений спосіб вивчення історії.
Весь той позитив, весь той потенціал,
який має реконструкція
для освітньої популяризаційної роботи,
ми втілюємо в музеї.
Це і костюмовані інтерактивні екскурсії,
і виготовлення макетів та моделей
того, чого зараз у замку немає,
але хотілося б показати.
Як, наприклад, виставка артилерії,
що майже на 90 % є реконструкцією.
Єдине, чим ми тут вихваляємося, як оригіналами,
це кам'яні ядра з території фортеці.
Це от дійсно оригінали.
Йдемо показувати, як стріляти треба.
Тут використовуються трошки м'якші та легші луки.
Бо люди не завжди можуть їх натягнути
і тут невеличка дистанція,
тож нема сенсу робити їх сильнішими.
Все дуже просто.
Ми їх повністю обслуговуємо.
Тут вам усе розкажуть про луки,
дадуть спробувати постріляти з різних видів.
Ми займаємося реконструкцією
подій та побуту XVII століття
та більш ранніх епох, а також луками.
Робимо традиційні, рекурсивні
і найбільше східні луки.
Бо вони найбільше стосуються  нашої історії.
Ми робимо і дитячі луки, і дорослі луки.
І стараємося робити їх як справжні.
У цьому луці є сучасний композит.
Бо для того, щоб робити «білий» композит,
потрібні сухожилля, ріг та дерево.
Це власне лук.
Але такий лук коштуватиме близько 1000 євро.
Ми використовуємо так званий «карбон».
В усьому іншому лук не відрізняється
від тих, що були раніше.
Ми робимо історичні луки.
Вони використовуються в образах реконструкції.
Ми постійно розвиваємося. Потроху.
Маленькими кроками, але завжди.
Щоб бути кращими.
Треба не влучити в ціль,
а зробити правильний постріл.
Коли ти все зробив правильно, ти влучиш у ціль.
Просто влучити в ціль можна й випадково.
А треба робити так,
щоб ціль була успіхом.
Зараз у всього, що стосується таких знакових
для України періодів, як XVII століття,
в масовій культурі образи та стереотипи
помилкові майже на 100 %.
Ми вивчаємо досвід і дуже хотілося б наслідувати це.
Насамперед американську практику
музеїв живої історії.
В Україні вже теж є кілька таких музеїв,
але вони ще тільки розвиваються.
Ця програма започаткована 2012 року.
Вона називається «Жива фортеця».
Це спроба насичити статичний музей
інтерактивом та динамікою.
Саме тоді тут з'явилися гончари.
Взагалі, ідея таких місць в замку в тому,
щоб люди спробували своїми руками,
не просто подивилися, а щось відчули.
Музеїв і експозицій вистачає усюди.
А живих об'єктів дуже мало.
Люди приходять, виготовлюють вироби.
Ми їх випалюємо і потім їм відправляємо.
За рік замок відвідують близько 100 000 людей.
Майстер-класів за записом я проводжу тисячу.
Буває 2-3 людини в одному,
буває група 40 чоловік.
Тобто за рік десь 1200-1300 майстер-класів буває.
Головне — бажання.
Даю глину — робимо.
З'явилися майстри, що демонструють власні ремесла,
проводять майстер-класи.
Зараз у нас з'явилися зародки замкової кухні,
а саме реконструкція хлібної печі.
Роблю без вищого сорту борошна.
Беремо висівкове борошно, буває,
на жорнах ще мелемо, висіваємо на ситі.
Другий сорт борошна,
щоб перший не використовувати.
Бо з першого сорту будь-хто може зробити.
А от з другого — трошки важче.
Колись тут ходили хлопці в парадних костюмах.
Мене це зацікавило,
постійно мріяв хоч би сфоткатися з ними.
А тут в один прекрасний момент
познайомився з Олегом-гончаром
і почав тут працювати.
Він вступив у товариство, сшив собі костюм.
Якось зайшов з хлопцями в костюмах
і я такий: «Опа-на, це ж моя мрія зараз збудеться».
Сфоткався, поговорив з ними.
Привітався, руку потиснув.
Думаю: «Ого, нічого собі».
Питаю його: «Як ти вступив? Бачу,
костюм собі вже пошив. Треба щось платити?».
Каже: «Ні, просто купляєш домоткане полотно,
кроєш-шиєш собі костюм і ти вже у товаристві.
Ти вже такий самий, як ми».
Думаю: «Нічого собі, то я вже готовий».
Це дуже цікаво, затягнуло.
Людям подобається,
деякі по два рази приїжджають
і зразу приходять сюди на хліб.
Бо сподобався.
Як кажуть, треба душу вложити.
З любов'ю ставитися
і тоді виходитиме добре.
Всяке перепробував,
на будівництвах працював.
І за кордон пропонували.
Але я кажу: «Нє, якщо в мене є руки, ноги і голова,
то ті самі гроші, що я зароблю за кордоном,
можна заробити і у нас в Україні».
Поки що в Україні є неочевидним
для широкого загалу те,
що туризм, можливість кудись їхати
й особливо можливість привозити людей сюди,
здатна змінювати міста і регіони.
Це в реконструкторів зараз такий тренд —
XVII століття, боротьба з шароварщиною.
До того ж у прямому сенсі цього слова.
Річ у тому, що шаровари як такі
в моді на наших теренах з'являються
у другій половині XVIII століття.
Тобто у XVII столітті, нічого,
пов'язаного із широкими штанами
і вишиванками і близько не було.
А тепер уявіть собі стереотипи
людини початку ХХІ століття,
коли їй говорять про козаків чи щось таке.
Це ж обв’язково дядько в червоних чоботях,
в шароварах і вишиванці.
Ми оцей стереотип хочемо трошки міняти
і показувати, що українці це не це і не тільки це.
Тобто ось це — теж українці.
І мені здається, що майбутнє України,
національної ідеї, в розумінні саме цього.
Україна була різна завжди.
Не можна говорити,
що вона була тільки там, а тут ні.
Це неправильно.
Це мої такі переконання
і до цього ми потрошку йдемо.